DAVID THORBURN: One of the
central arguments of my film
course-- and this
is one of the ways
it's different from
a traditional film
course in a university,
in a cinema studies
program, or even in an English
department-- is that it sees
the advent of television as a
critical factor in the history
of the movies, much more
central and critical than most
contemporary
histories acknowledge.
Because what I try to
show is that the function
that the movies had in American
society before the advent
of television was the
function that the novel had
in the 19th Century in
Europe, and the function
that Shakespeare's public
theater had in Shakespeare's
day, a form of popular narrative
that's articulated a kind of
assumed or imagine
consensus of values
for the whole of the society.
That made it a culturally,
and anthropologically,
and socially much
more important medium
then a mere artistic
medium, even
though it's artistic quality
remains very important.
So that one of the
ironies of entertainment
is it can become a
space, especially
public forms of
entertainment in cultures,
like Shakespeare's
public theater,
or like the public theater
of the American movie
system in the studio era, these
public spaces can become spaces
in which the body politic, the
political and social community
entertains ideas
about its own nature,
entertains,
considers, speculates,
holds in its mind
accounts of its origins,
stories of its values
And what we can say then
is that the space
of entertainment
becomes from in a certain angle
in virtually all societies,
a space of discourse, a space
in which-- exactly because it's
a space recognized as not
real, as make believe,
is therefore licensed or
allowed to explore possibilities
that might be too dangerous
or too disturbing to explore
in other way.
And I taught both television
and film in this way.
In an ironic way, it's
a deeply literary way
to teach the medium.
So the argument ends up
being that the movies
after television, the
movies after about 1970,
are profoundly a
different animal.
The old studio system is dead.
Movies have become
much more single,
individual deal-making
events using great stars,
and particularly bankable
scriptwriters, and scripts,
and so forth, nothing
like the great factory
for the making of
stories, the story machine
that the movies had been until
the advent of television,
and that television became
as it took on that consensus
function.
I think it's a powerful
and central insight that
helps to explain the
tremendous changes that
overtake American
movies after, certainly,
after 1970 and beyond.
Another way in which
I think my film course
is not fully a film course,
even though every text we study
is a movie, all the scholarship
site is movie schol-- not all.
But some is movie scholarship.
And I try to teach them about
the history of film in ways
that I think are
helpful to them.
But there is a profoundly
literary dimension
to my teaching.
And I think of as deeply
as a literature course.
It's a course that,
if a student takes,
serves as a prerequisite for
advanced subjects in literature
as well as in media.
And my reasons
for that is that I
treat the problems one confronts
in a film from the perspective
of a professor of literature,
from the perspective of one
who's a specialist in narrative.
Remember, many of the narratives
that I have taught all my life
we're not printed
texts like novels.
They wear all narratives,
like Homer's Odyssey.
Or, they were dramatic
presentations.
Like Shakespeare's plays.
Literature has never
meant simply printed text.
And I think my field is
narrative of all sorts.
And what I try to do is show
them, among other things,
certain kinds of
linkages or continuities
across different
forms of narrative.
And I certainly try
to make them see
that movies in a certain era,
television in another era,
were like the literature
of earlier eras.
And it makes my film course a
much more centrally literary
and humanistic subject than
would be the case if it
were taught in a more
conventional kind of cinema
studies sequence.